our car tester undred cemani didn't
initially like the Opel Adam but now
he's used to its design when he heard
there was going to be a sport version he
was curious what a small car like this
have what it takes
today we're going to find out whether
the developers have succeeded mirror
mirror on the wall who's the sportiest
of them all with the Adam that's
obviously the S version Opel has already
sold over 125,000 Adams the S variant is
now meant for those who are looking for
a sports car in the a segment the
engineers have reworked the body
accordingly so often and races mission
accomplished the Adam s drives sport
early and the steering is tighter and
offers more feedback than in the regular
Adam the heart of the sport Adam is
nevertheless the 1.4 liter Ecotec turbo
engine with variable valve control it
produces 110 kilowatts that's enough to
push the 1.2 tonnes to 100 km/h in eight
and a half seconds
but in our car tester thinks some people
will say the adamant accelerate fast
enough and is underpowered but
specifications are one thing at the
driving experience another and it seems
the driving experience is a euphoric one
for Andre he moves through turns at high
speed keeping a tight grip on the
steering wheel always ready to engage
one of the six years in combination with
the optional 18-inch rims the 225
millimeter wide tires transmit the
performance directly onto the street
the brake callipers of the Animus
deserve their red finish they were
developed by the Opel Performance Center
team small spoiler lips next to the air
ducts also underlined the athletic
character of this fun vehicle the rear
features a spoiler and diffuser
entre is impressed with the engine it
screams when you step on the gas and
ribs smoothly up to 6000 rpm on the
inside are specially designed dashboard
inlays providing a real sports car feel
the instruments have a carbon look and
an S logo is of course a must our test
car also features blue leather
embellishments in various places you can
invest up to two thousand ten euros in
extras for the seats the Adam S is a
real speedster says Andre to keep your
grip in a curve definitely opt for one
thing from the accessory list the Recaro
sports seats they offer great side
support when needed in urban traffic
these seats aren't too uncomfortable
either the Adam s manages the balancing
act between City Car & speedster
excellently but you generally buy the S
variant for the latter rather than to
have a car that's easy to park while
shopping this spoiler isn't for pushing
a shopping cart around says Andre the
Adam s is a real sports car with -
potential unfortunately there are always
some drawbacks curving around at high
speed obviously can't keep the specified
average fuel consumption at 5.9 liters
that will put you closer to seven or
eight liters and the price could be too
high for most people who just want to
have fun you have to pay at least
eighteen thousand six hundred ninety
euros to get the go-cart feeling with
the lightning bolt on the radiator
you